when you do it it's a fear fish you
infinite horizon you must be a sailor to
you I take it I don't consider myself a
sailor for me this felt like a departure
from the sort of previous films that
we've done I know you don't but it felt
more kind of adult and mature and real
like there's a real authentic kind of
feel about it and the fact that it is a
true story kind of adds so much more
drama to it sort of rocks your
heartstrings in a different way I retain
Raymond between upgrade into a category
5 what bothers are was very keen for us
to do is to kind of literally live the
journey ourselves go on that
rollercoaster ride live on the ocean
almost I was very clear to the studio
the only way I want to do this movie is
shooting it on the water as much as
possible
I love how nature kind of strips you and
it makes things war and your monsters
war and is really truly a place where
you are and I think in this opportunity
of making a survival story with a woman
I think it's about time that we realize
women have had - and your nature as well
my ribs broken Alex Shepherd from
deadweight sailing was also the role and
requires more from her since diving
under 55 footer we shot it all in the
ocean
nothing shot in tanks no underwater suit
says an attack is ocean no it's done
project he's doing it all himself
I talked to Balthazar and he said
between you two that Shailene would
definitely be the one to survive oh my
lord
I don't that's definitely not true and
that several easily bolt would say I
don't think he likes me that he was
serious and I have no idea he was joking
to be fair I don't want a city boy
generally and you know I'm a dad I wear
Crocs for a living
[Music]
you